-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
Bridget Everett, music from
Red Hot Chili Peppers
is on the way,
but first, it's time
to play "Box of Lies."
[ Cheering and applause ]
The game,
if you don't know,
works like this.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing who knows what.
These are mystery items
in the mystery boxes.
Hugh will pick a box.
He will remove the object
and describe it to his opponent,
which is me,
and then I have to guess
if he was lying
or telling the truth
about what's in the box.
And, based
on your customs story,
it seems like I should win
this pretty easily.
[ Laughter ]
-Just take it now.
-And we'll play two rounds.
Loser has to eat a rat, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-Yay! Awesome.
-Alright, here we go.
You pick first.
You're the guest.
Go crazy.
-Alright, let's go for it.
1, 2, or 3?
-3!
3? 3 it is. I heard 3.
-[ Laughs ]
People really have a strong
opinion on a number.
[ Laughter ]
-And, while I'm pulling
this out,
I know we're playing a game,
but Ahmir, Questlove,
that movie "Summer of Soul"?
You have to see it.
Won the Oscar
for Best Documentary.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Ooh!
[ Laughing ]
Oh, hoh, ooh, yes.
[ Laughter ]
I like it.
Oh, I really like it.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-You can keep it, probably.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, you know what?
I'm not going to keep this one.
-Oh.
-This kind of -- Yeah.
-Okay.
-Scare small children.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so, wow.
So it's jelly,
like a jelly mold,
circular jelly,
and, inside it...
♪♪
...I'm presuming,
is fake poo.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, interesting.
-Mm.
-Now, I'm going to say,
not necessarily based
on your delivery,
but, based on the fact that
that would be
an exceptionally disgusting
thing to put in a box...
[ Laughter ]
...that you, Hugh Jackman,
are lying.
-You're accusing me of lying?
[ Laughter ]
Damn it!
I'm really bad at lying!
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
Damn it!
-What do we have here?
Ooh, a little diorama.
-By the way, I am keeping that.
It's so good.
-Oh, look at that, yeah.
Wow! look at that.
-That is so good.
-You're about to kill
Professor X.
[ Laughter ]
That doesn't seem in keeping
with the canon of the --
-Giving him a nice close shave.
-I don't know what we do
with these now.
-I don't know what we do,
either.
-Alright, now,
it's time for me to pick a box.
-Can I keep this, by the way?
-I am going to take
number...
-5!
-Your opinions are not welcome.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
I'm going with number 6
because it's the closest one.
Alright?
-Alright.
♪♪
Alright. Okay.
Alright.
This is --
Show it to the audience.
[ Laughter ]
This is a cake
with shrimp cocktail
on top of it
and it says...
[ Laughter ]
...on it.
-[ Laughing ] It's just --
just way too good to be true.
That's way too good to be true
and I have a funny feeling,
Jimmy,
that you may want to show that
you're a better liar than me.
That's just my gut.
I'm sensing a little --
-Why would anyone want
to show that?
In fact...
-Everybody is.
-...something I'd keep
quiet, probably.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Jimmy, you're lying.
I know you're lying.
-I would never lie to you,
Hugh Jackman.
[ Sad trombone, rimshot ]
In fact, it's this.
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
It's weird, right?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Is that game over?
-I think the game's over.
-I think I won.
-I told you.
I'm the worst liar.
[ Rimshot ]
I can't even spot a lie.
-You got a show to go to.
Hugh Jackman is
in "The Music Man."
You will never get tickets
to this, so forget about it,
[ Laughter ]
but, on the off chance you do,
it's at the
Winter Garden Theatre.
-And, if you come,
I want you to know,
somewhere on the stage,
this will be there,
and I'm not lying. Somewhere.
-Oh. that's wonderful.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, Hugh,
I'm going to tell you that
we're going to send this
to Ryan Reynolds,
for his house.
-Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
-Hugh Jackman, everybody.